hello there welcome back it's time to
break down issue one of the fortnite
zero war comic book series in which
marvel heroes are back again to help us
save reality it's tough to get a series
like this off the ground so if you could
do me a favor and leave a like and a
comment that would really help anyway
there's a lot to cover so let's do this
the story opens in the princess bar
that's a marvel drinking establishment
found in a fictional country called
madrapor it's in south asia and
wolverine loves to hang out here the
locals call him patch suddenly
spider-man sits down next to him and
immediately wolverine knows he wants
some help no he proclaims no to whatever
insane crap you're fixing to drag me
into before we know it both jones and
the imagined have joined the bar the
imagined is being herself she's flirting
with wolverine she's so forward her
presence makes peter sweat with nervous
anticipation i'm the imagined this is
agent jones we need your help wolverine
the four sit down with a drink and
spider-man tells us of the daily bugles
vanishing and being taken to a different
reality that explains why it's still in
fortnite right now the daily bugle will
be coming home soon we are given a
flashback to an epic battle between the
7 and io and we get a nice piece of
recapping and clarification the island
is a different universe the place where
every reality came from we are also
reminded that the big bang theory we're
told about in science class actually
formed the zero point and reality zero
the zero point has been controlled by
the imagined order for thousands of
years to take technology artifacts and
people from other realities and it turns
out this flashback is set during last
season season two of chapter three the
resistance storyline so effectively this
happens just before the collider is
built
the way spider-man explains the
foundation is top class imagine if tony
stark was nick fury but built like the
hulk pretty good compliment the recap
ends with sloan and gunner pressing the
self-destruct button sloan wants to cut
their losses and gunner is fine with
that this leads to our first sad moment
the death of fish sticks reminding us
that those outside the loop will not
respawn they are gone forever but wait a
minute fish sticks has already died if
you remember the dc fortnite comic book
run you'll vividly remember fish sticks
being offed by deathstroke it seems like
this is going to be a running gag fish
sticks will be cannon fodder in each
series kinda like kenny in south park
sleep well sweet prince the foundation
tells eight ball that this fish sticks
was a snapshot and he'll be back in the
loop any second now revealing the real
fish sticks is already dead eight ball
doesn't know how to take this he's sort
of stuck in shock the battle we oversee
is for an io outpost remember these one
fell every update and now we have info
on how that happened sloan blew them up
while retreating to prevent information
from falling into the sevens hands
four of the seven are talking openly
about defeating the io and the visitor
has an idea to find paradigm and the
mecca let's pause here for a second as
this is the first real evidence we have
that paradigm was responsible for
constructing the mech and not
singularity as hinted in chapter one
it's widely believed that singularity
and the paradigm are the same person but
we don't know 100 for sure we receive a
bunch of lore panels to confirm
everything the paradigm is the missing
member of the seven kind of a sensitive
subject she did a heel turn changed
sides and joined up with the imagined
order so there we have it it's confirmed
io and the paradigm worked together to
build the mech in order to defeat the
polar peak monster the visitor confirms
that none of the seven saw this but the
story came directly from jones who at
the time was working for the imagined
order 2 meaning all the months of
distrust of paradigm came directly from
jones the origin informs us the mecca
crash landed on the moon and then fills
in one of the biggest plot holes in
fortnite history the random ice block
that santa rocked up on all those years
ago that actually was on the moon a
frozen mass which fell to the island and
slowly drifted over it's moon ice and
that creature was an alien from the moon
fortnite keeps getting weirder back on
the island the origin believes the
paradigm is likely dead on the moon from
exposure to the cold but the foundation
refuses to let the mecca go unused
spider-man joins the conversation with a
request if you can get me back to my
world i can recruit a whole army of
tough customers some of them have even
been here before the order then whips
out an io portal device the same kind we
saw agent jones use in the zero crisis
finale the thing is though it only has
two charges remaining so it's confirmed
those portal devices are not unlimited
they are indeed finite who'da thunk it
the origin in particular wants
spider-man to bring back the two
superheroes that can manipulate the
weather before i say who they are here's
five seconds can you guess who the two
marvel heroes who can change the weather
did you get it course you did it's storm
and thor both have been here before the
scientist wants the pair to make the
moon more habitable by changing the
weather therefore we can get to the moon
and charge the mech ready for battle and
as we all know that's exactly what we
did everyone agrees and jones and peter
begin their adventure but wait there's a
second mission given to us by the origin
himself we need a flashback for this
during the galactus event it turns out
the devourer of worlds dislodged a piece
of the orb and it was transported back
to the marvel world through that
butterfly rift and now origen wants it
back his plan is to use it on the broken
mecca on the moon to charge it quickly
just like the paradigm did during the
final showdown charging it in seconds
and not months suddenly the sisters
imagined and order chime in my sister's
going with you it's not that we don't
trust you we just have a personal stake
in this and then the imagined interrupts
it is that we don't trust you jones was
one of them and we don't know the skinny
guy at all if you've played fortnite
during season 2 of this chapter you'll
know all about the memory loss of at
least one of those sisters and how they
have been working alone on secret
projects that the other members of the
seven don't know about the sisters are
looking like double agents with an
ulterior motive but what could it be for
the order must stay behind to fight and
the two hug it out the imagine says they
can't spare us both order i'll be back
soon and we'll get what we waited so
long for i really don't trust those two
[Music]
jones takes the team to a waste disposal
pipe his plan is to get in through toxic
waste it's a little weird and it
involves piggybacking on the armored
members of the seven and then getting as
close as possible this means when they
cloak and go invisible so do the other
two characters after a scuffle or two
the team make it to a secret door oh and
i should say that the entire base is
upside down right now the flip made
everything in io's secret base
completely the wrong way around it's so
confusing that spider-man asks if
mysterio is still playing tricks on him
this could be a simple nod to another
character or maybe mysterio is coming to
the future episodes fishbowl head coming
to fortnite we've already got a few
fishbowls here already jones leads us to
his former office it's quite a sad
moment this he genuinely looks quite sad
poor guy needs a moment to remember his
former life he then takes a photo as a
memento before moving on i used imposter
mode to try and find that picture it
wasn't there and only the wall images
were present i also checked the
impostor's trailer and found this is
this the image jones treasures most the
og astronaut skin from season three flex
in the comments if you own it
the quartet finally make it to the zero
point it lies in ruin from both being
flipped and the io's excavation above
creating the collider foundation tells
us this is the source of everything to
which spider-man says wow i've never
seen anything quite like this and i've
fought a giant armadillo another name
drop from spider-man and he's totally
right he fought a guy called antonio
rodriguez who really was a giant
armadillo and i would totally buy that
skin the foundation warns peter to not
touch the zero point until it's
calibrated we've seen what happens if
you touch it too early eternal voyager
did this in the batman zero point run
and was torn into a million pieces
spread across unlimited realities so yes
buddy don't don't touch it suddenly the
foundation is shot in the back sloan and
gonna appear io expected jones to come
through his office and set up an alarm
mid-battle jonesy tells us where jenna
is the problem is he thinks geno is
gunner he honestly thinks gunner and
geno are the same person sloane laughs
and says you think geno has time to
waste on the likes of you jones rewind
back to chapter 2 and the entire promise
jones made to the foundation was to give
him geno
i can get you to jenna and now we know
he doesn't even know who jenno is jones
is mortified he's worked for io for
centuries and geno never knew he existed
right in the fields wait a second he's
worked for io for centuries i may be
reading too much into this but this
implies io agents don't age the same way
as you and i and it also means that
jones is at the very least 200 years old
200. i wonder how old bunker johnsy is
the fight continues as jonesy
frantically calibrates the zero point
the second it is ready spider-man picks
him up and they both jump into the spear
spider-man cleverly uses a web to reset
the location so nobody can follow them
big brain
remember at the end of chapter two
gunner was completely out fought by the
foundation having his face smashed into
this unit then in chapter three he was
given new super powered gauntlets and
today we saw him use them gunner
uppercuts the foundation so hard he
flies through the ceiling and back above
ground he is formidable now sloane
remains committed to the plan the
collider will wipe out all her enemies
in just a matter of days
[Music]
we jump to reality 616 with spider-man
and jones as they look up to see this
site the imagined has picked a fight
with carol danvers in her first minute
in this reality spider-man quickly gets
between the two and proclaims they are
on the same side and attempts to get the
avengers together ought to put it his
way we need a big hero meeting the four
of them travel to avengers mountain the
place the first celestial visited earth
and gave us all life it's found in the
north pole so they traveled quite a long
way it somehow became the headquarters
of earth's mightiest heroes even though
it's in the remains of this thing inside
we see captain america thor iron man
storm she-hulk black panther and of
course captain marvel all of these
characters have been to the island
before but there are also others here
like vision and quicksilver if you know
the name of the other ones please put it
in the comments and i will pin your
comment anyway spider-man explains the
war for the zero point and immediately
iron man takes over and organizes
everything just like he did last time
and to his credit he did save us last
time this leaves jones peter and the
imagined to find the shard of the zero
point as instructed by the origin and it
just so happens to be 100 miles away
coincidence
and now that brings us up to date back
in the bar with wolverine everyone is
crazy drunk right now and still trying
to convince logan to join them and as it
turns out he only needed to hear one
thing it'll be the best fight you ever
had wolverine officially joins the team
the only thing to do now is set up the
bad guys of this series and it's dr doom
watching from doom castle he isn't doing
this alone our final bombshell of the
issue is simply one word geno geno and
dr doom are working together they are
one step ahead of our heroes but wait
there's more geno officially invites dr
doom to the inner circle of the imagined
order a secret group who control all of
reality to be continued i'm adam you're
awesome i hope you liked that i'll see
you again next month
[Music]
you